welcome back to PB on S my next guest is
one of the most influential to many
controversial political scientists in
the world most recently he started
controversy with his ferocious criticism
of Israel's attacks on Gaza many of you
have called for him to appear on this
show with thousands of comments like
this one I wonder if P morg going to be
brave enough to have Norman finlin on
his show well I'm pleased to say the
answer is yes because we believe in
being uncensored here and hearing from
all voices and so I'm joined Now by
Professor Norman finkl Professor thank
you very much indeed for joining me I
appreciate it and like I said a lot of
people wanted a lot of people wanted me
to interview you yourself tweeted that
the we we hadn't done it so here we are
I'm glad about it um I think you're an
influential voice and you've obviously
been very vocal about this since it all
kicked off I want to take you back uh if
if I may to the to October the 7th
because your first reaction to What
happened on October the 7th incensed
many people uh you uh posted on Su stack
uh a piece about what had happened on
the day and it included this for the
past 20 years of people of Gaza half of
whom are children have been immured in a
concentration camp today they breach the
Camp's walls if we honor John Brown's
armed resistance to slavery if we honor
the Jews who revolted in the war so
ghetto the moral consistency commands
and we honor the heroic resistance in
Gaza I for one will never begrudge on
the contrary it warms every fiber of my
soul the scenes of are smiling children
as their arrogant Jewish supremacist
oppressors have finally been humbled and
you ended by saying the stars above in
heaven are looking kindly down Glory
Glory Hallelujah The Souls of Gaza go
marching
on with the benefit of of a few weeks
now do you regret the tone of that
initial response to what
happened my initial response was to the
initial news stories you will recall all
I'm sure that initially what we were
informed was that there was a break uh
breakout from Gaza concentration camp
that approximately 1,500 people had
broken out and that about 50 people that
was the initial number that was given
approximately 50 Israelis were killed
the number gradually grew went from 50 a
couple of days later it went to 100 and
I'm sure you'll remember the number
didn't reach 1,400 until about 10 days
later initially it was reasonable excuse
me it was reasonable to assume that
people had been killed in a firefight
which was not the case at least not
fully the case so my initial reaction
was to the initial news stories by the
third or fourth day I was is clearly
compelled to rethink my initial
statements and try to make sense of what
was clearly a moral quander and at that
point I revised my not revised but I uh
considered my judgment on the basis of
the new information that was available
okay and my own sense yes go Ahad that's
what I I just want to look I've done a
Time line uh for my own benefit uh based
on what happened that day we know the
attacks began at 6:30 in the morning uh
we know that at
11:18 a.m. Israel confirmed as you say
40 dead 700 injured at 11:35 Benjamin
Netanyahu said we are at War at 12:30
that day at lunchtime I tweeted
horrifying and appalling scenes from
Israel this murderous indiscriminate
Hamas terror attack on Israeli people is
shameful and indefensible by
4117 Israel said 100 were dead at least
985 wounded civilian hostages have been
taken at 4:00 a little later than that
around the same time footage has
released of attack reporting that
3,000 bombs and Firearms have been fired
off by Hamas civilians have been killed
and so on and yet at 6:30 and then again
at at
916 you were retweeting your initial uh
substep back uh and you then added at
9116 uh that the you felt the hostage
situation was crocodile tears so I would
take issue uh with your uh statement
that you thought it was only after two
or three days anyone had a clue about
the scale of what had happened here it
was very obvious during that Saturday
about the mounting scale of horror and I
just don't understand why someone as
scholarly as you as expert in this
region in this conflict as you are why
your response would be that for several
days one of glorifying in the uh in what
in what you called heroic resistance
whereas mine and I've always tried to be
fair-minded about this conflict and
reported it for CNN and tried to be fair
and accurate as of when I've seen it uh
that I at midday that day I'm talking
about a murderous indiscriminate terror
attack and horrifying and appalling
scenes I just don't I just don't believe
that you weren't aware with great
respect about the scale of what was
going
on okay Pierce let me Begin by saying I
want to have a civil
conversation and I'm going to do my
darnest to remain faithful to the facts
and faithful to truth I'll do my darness
not to exaggerate the first thing I have
to say is I don't tweet I've never been
on Twitter I have three young teex
people who I send statements to and then
they make the decision where to place it
on substack on Twitter and so forth okay
I just want to clear that up I made one
statement on the first day on the basis
of the information that was available to
me the information was 50 people had
been killed now my memory is but I won't
claim my memory is infall
the numbers didn't start to grow until
the next day that's not true as the
numbers okay it's just not true here's
well Professor with respect I'm not
going it's not true Pi Piers Piers yeah
but you have to listen to what I say but
you want me to you want me to believe
you and you say you weren't aware of the
scale of this for several days and I
find that just I'm incredulous you want
me to believe that okay Pi Pierce Pierce
I'm not going to force you to to believe
it and I'm not going to even try to
impose my will I'm simply saying as a
factual matter speaking for myself I was
not aware that the numbers had been
beyond 50 when I made that statement I
will further State I will further state
that to my knowledge I could be mistaken
that I did not make another
statement until the numbers start to
grow and I admit I have said to you it
was a moral quander for me and I said in
many interviews that it was for me a
very burdened moment because I wasn't
entirely confident in my moral judgment
and it was at that point that I start to
look back at what the white
abolitionists had to say when Nat Turner
carried out a slave rebellion and many
whites
were uh hacked to death children were
beheaded and I wanted to see because I
was not confident of my moral judgment I
wanted to see what did the white
abolitionists those who fought against
SL y had to say and I looked at what
William Lloyd Garrison probably the most
famous of the white abolitionists and he
said horrible things happened during Nat
Turner's Rebellion but if you read his
statement he wouldn't condemn Nat Turner
or Nat Turner let me okay so let me ask
you oh let me ask you okay I've heard
you say this before that analogy that's
fine but let me me ask you given you now
know the scale of what happened given
you know 12200 people were killed
including 800 or so completely innocent
civilians we we know that children were
killed that grandmothers were killed and
their deaths FaceTime to their families
we know that over 200 people were were
kidnapped and taken hostage given you
know the full scale of this attack I've
asked a lot of guests this these two
questions and i' be curious about your
answer one would you categorize it as a
terror attack attack and secondly would
you condemn Hamas for what they
did my view is as follows number one as
far as the evidence shows now atrocities
occurred on October 7th the magnitude of
the atrocities and the types of
atrocities for example where children
beheaded were women raped That Remains
so far as I can tell from the evidence
an open question however that there were
atrocities that occurred my answer is
yes number two that's a that's a factual
question then there's question was was a
terror
attack yeah well atrocities it seems to
me denotes a terror attack okay that's
what atrocities are okay so number two
that's the factual question
and then there is the legal question as
a matter of law it seems
unquestionable that the people who
perpetrated these atrocities would be
prosecuted and convicted in the court of
law however I would say on the legal
question I should think that there would
be some mercy shown because those who
carried out the atrocities were
concentration camp inmates number three
which I think is the one that concerns
you the most is the moral question and
at a moral level my view is my basic
precept we may disagree my basic precept
is that they're but for the grace of God
go I that is to say I'm very reluctant
to condemn people who are in a position
or in a condition such that were I in
that position or condition I'm not sure
what I would do now the 1500 young men
who burst the gates of Gaza they were
born into a concentration camp they
lived for two decades in a concentration
camp they had no past they had no
present they had no future they had no
jobs half of them according to
humanitarian organizations suffered from
what's called severe food
insecurity and then on top of that as
I'm sure you know Pierce because you
keep up with the news periodically
Israel goes into Gaza and it Ms the lawn
and you know what Ms the lawn means it
means a Hightech massacre in Gaza in
20089 operation cast Le
2012 operation pillar of
Defense
2014 operation protective Edge and on
each of these high tech massacres
visited on the people of
Gaza in some cases hundreds in some
cases thousands of Palestinians are
killed okay and let me ask in fact just
an oper let me ask on that point in
light of
one question about that in that period
yes in that period And by the way I I've
been condemnatory of some of the things
you've just talked about publicly I've
tweeted my condemnation of some of these
things uh and I've I've tried to shine a
light on the plot of the Palestinians
for many many years and I feel that the
oppression uh of the Palestinian people
for many decades has been absolutely
outrageous so on that we can completely
agree um but when it comes to what
you're saying here it seems to me what
you're trying to paint is a picture of
some kind of moral justification for
what Hamas did and that's where you lose
me because I don't see why there could
be any anyone who can see the scale of
what Hamas did on October 7th and not
simply condemn it out of hand you may
also want to condemn some of the
response by Israel that's completely
normal I would say that there are
serious question marks about the
proportionality of what they've been
doing but if you can't start from a
basic Humanity position of saying what
happened on October the 7th was a a
disgusting terror attack worthy of
condemnation then for me I find it very
hard to then respect anyone's demand for
people to condemn Israel and their
response appears I'm really and I'm
trying to be candid with you number one
I appreciate your Humanity I do I don't
know you from Adam I'm not a TV or a
television or social media kind of
person I'm a book person I'm
oldfashioned however I do recall that
when that famous moment when Susan Bole
appeared on Britain's God talent and I
remember the
camera turning to you focusing on you I
can see it in my mind's eye I saw your
eyes narrow and suddenly the humanity in
you came up here is this obscure woman
whose Talent
had gone
unrecognized and if I can speak to that
same program for me the most poent
moment the one I carry with me my enti
since that moment was when Simon Cowell
asked um Susan Bole well why haven't you
been discovered yet and she replied
because I haven't been given a
chance and that's how I feel about the
people of Gaza
that's how I feel about those young men
in Gaza you ask me why I won't condemn
them because those young men were born
into a concentration camp they were born
into among the most dense po uh
populated places on on God's
Earth half of the population of gods's
children 70% are refugees who were
expelled from Israel in
1948 and their
descendants 70% of those of God's youth
have no jobs no future no nothing they
are Susan Bole times
10,000 never given a chance and as
things looked the night before October
7th when the question of Gaza was
disappearing from the public stage I
will admit to you peers I
myself had given up on Gaza in
2020 I decided it's
hopeless it's
pointless I only have a finite number of
years left in my life and it's time for
me to move on and I'll tell you that was
a wrench ing decision on my part because
I knew I was abandoning the people who
for 15
years I had devoted my life to
chronicling every
detail of the horror that had been
inflicted on those
people and I gave up on them okay and
that meant if I gave up they had no
future because I was the last chronicler
okay but what I would say Gaza I have
the only book profess that's been
written on let me respond let me respond
what I would respond I would respond by
saying that what people in Israel would
say and what Jewish people would say
particular who live in Israel is that
they were facing a constant barrage of
rockets from Hamas Hamas won political
power in
20056 that they were given a huge amount
of money uh and could have done what
whatever they wanted with that money but
chose to pursue a path of effectively
terrorizing uh the Israelis over that
period and the israelies you're right
they responded in a they have a far
superior military and they responded in
the way that they did and this cycle has
been going on and repeat and repeat and
repeat but where you and I differ about
this is that I think what happened on
October the 7th was just uh on a
different scale to anything we've seen
and the way it was carried out and I
just don't think saying that people who
have been oppressed which they
undoubtedly were for many years that
that justifies them committing that act
of Terror but let's take a break let's
come back after the break and and
discuss this
more welcome back I'm still with
Professor Norman finlin Professor just
to round off what we've just been
discussing given that you wrote that
substi uh and you you want me to believe
and okay I'll take your word for it you
were completely oblivious to the reality
of what had happened here on the scale
of it um but given you're not now
oblivious to that why have you not
removed that substat given the language
is so clearly offensive to people and
you based it by your own words on a
false premise about what had
happened you know Pierce that's a very
good question and this morning when I
was talking to some friends from the
UK I was warned you would ask that
question I'll honestly tell you I never
fear the truth I don't I feel the truth
is a very powerful weapon on the side of
the oppressed I never fear it now I'm
going to give you the answer again you
can or can't disagree with me or believe
me I was tempted to remove it I was
tempted to quote unquote protect
myself I didn't remove it because I
thought that's
intellectually
dishonest I wrote that
statement it's part of the historical
record it's part of the documentary
record and I shouldn't do what Stalin
used to do so when he published
photographs of the bolik Revolution he
would take trotsky's picture out okay
that's the image so you won't delete so
that was that's the image that stuck to
me all right you I've going to delete it
but do do you do you regret
it do I regret what do you regret the
contents of that substack given that you
now know what really
happened yes if it can be
misconstrued to mean that I wrote that
with full knowledge of what happened of
course I regret it okay however it
remains part of the record and as a
serious scholar I'm not a great scholar
I'm not in the ranks of the Great
British historians but I take
scholarship seriously I did not want to
denature to falsify to misrepresent the
documentary record let me ask you let me
ask you let me ask and I will leave it
there okay okay that's listen that's
your decision you are the son of two
people who survived the Holocaust who
were both in concentration
camps uh you're a Jewish
man uh and you know how inury that
substack has proven to be with Jewish
people around the world who many of whom
have felt this is the nearest thing to
the Holocaust of World War II that
they've enured what your parents went
through being Revisited on them in these
kutes on October the 7th um what do you
feel about them I mean how would your
parents have felt about you literally on
the day that this happened talking about
heroic resistance talking about that you
will never begrudge the scenes uh that
you the stars in heaven are looking
kindly down Glory Glory The Souls of
Gaza go marching on how would your
parents have felt about that coming out
of concentration camp surviving the
Holocaust of World War
II well first of all anything I write I
have my parents looking at the screen
behind me over my shoulders in a
metaphorical sense I am very
conscious every moment of my existence
every moment of my existence goes back
to the martyrdom of my
family so it's not as if suddenly you're
posing a question to me that never
occurred to me quite the
contrary I do need even 30 years after
their death I
need the moral
validation that came from my parents
martyrdom and the extermination of their
family how would my parents have reacted
my gu is if on the first day they
heard that inmates in a concentration
camp burst its Gates I think my parents
would be very
pleased at that
fact as the events became
clearer my guess but this is pure
speculation my guess is my parents would
go out with their
hearts would go out to those who burst
the gates of the concentration camp and
whose lives were destroyed now you will
say to me completely legitimately you
would say what what would your parents
feel about the Innocents who were
slaughtered in the atrocities on that
date so I'm going to give you as close
an answer as I could give
I as I'm able to I once asked my late
mother I said to her what was your
feeling when you heard that the German
cities were being Terror bombed during
World War II the carpet bombing of the
German cities targeting civilians what
was your feeling and my mother's
response to me was
quote our feeling was if we're going to
to die we're going to take some of them
with us now that's not the most morally
elevated statement I
agree and do I wish my mother had and my
father had a heightened
sensitivity to German civilian life I
suppose I would wish it but I will tell
you pierce to the last day
of my parents life it was
Unthinkable that they would have a kind
word to say about
Germans and it was
Unthinkable that I would ever quarrel
with them on that point okay I accepted
I accepted that given their life
experience they had the right to hate
the people who destroyed their lives and
the people Gaza have the right to hate
the people who destroyed their lives
Professor figin uh thank you for the
answer and I don't mean to cut you off
we've got another guest waiting to
respond to what we've been discussing
I'd like to get you back on I feel like
we've had a a good conversation I don't
agree with you about some of it
obviously that's been clear but I
respect the tone that you've adopted for
the interview and i' would like to
explore more of this with you another
time I want to just say one last word
everybody warned me you wouldn't let me
speak that you would speak over me you
would stop me I want everybody to know
you are eminently fair you were decent
and you are that same human being whose
eyes narrowed as Susan Bole began to
perform okay you have that humanity and
I deeply respect it thank you Professor
I appreciate you coming on thank you
very
much